selber selbst gesetzt willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute zeige ich euch
was was schon 20.000 ja wie viel die oft
20.000 mal wurde nachgefragt dass ich
doch endlich mal bitten um zu machen
soll und heute leute ist es soweit
heute machen wir einen tour gut oder
und ich würde sagen wir fangen ja schon
mal ganz vorne an wir gehen mal hier
lang in richtung meines zimmers rocky 9
die wartet die neue box hat gar nicht
mehr zeigen hier haben wir auf jeden
fall kurz einmal motto gebt euch der
bambinis christ uhren mehr leute haltet
euch fest haltet euch fest weil wir
schon gesehen hat aber wie sie 3000
aerospace ein unterirdischer jam
oberirdischer djembé traumjob fußboden
parkett mein gott ist gefühlt putze ich
finde leute ganz ehrlich gibt es
irgendein youtuber hier so gut es nicht
gibt es irgendeinen platz nicht kommt
der gucken
inzwischen soll poster die einzige
dekoration nicht mehr im ganzen zimmer
ab ich brauche ich ma lin architekten
architekt irgendwie muss ich mal aushält
aschenbecher so lächerlich alter sie
diesen bitte seht ihr diese becher
das sind leere kaffeebecher hat mir
einfach einen von denen genommen weil
ich mit kelchen eichstätt haben einfach
aufgeschnitten darf ich packte meine
schlüssel rein und es ist einfach so
stark ist
aber er kommt herein kommen machen die
tour zurück zum hafen wir uns ganz
alleine und dem ordentlichen tüte mit
break denkt keiner gebrauchen kann
hier ist die softbox warum steht jetzt
hier im angefragt ihr euch weil ich
gerade eben eine story erzählen wollte
ob man doch dachte er macht lieber
erstmal die wut über die website
bisschen krass wenn die hören wollt dann
schaut doch einfach mal 30 millionen
likes sein so und dann kommen wir zum
größten teil meines zimmers einfach hier
die fucking wie du es nennen den wäsche
haufen und hier habe ich übrigens von
effekt schuhputzer seht ihr das zum
beispiel schwarzer schuhcreme hier hab
ich ja noch ein lappen weil ich ganz
gerne kleider schuhe trage so
klassischen schuhe und die ja immer
geputzt werden müssen natürlich deswegen
habe ich gesagt da und ich mag es
einfach ganz gerne auch ungewöhnlich vom
alter glaube ich die allermeisten sind
im mixed aber eben das sein ich hätte
niemanden dann sehen wir hier mitten im
zimmer den todesstern der ehrlichkeit
perfekt fixiert ist aber es wird besser
leute immer wieder jede menge wird hier
zum beispiel auf dem schrank des microsd
karte auf der kamera drauf ist hier ein
album für smartphone beim rennen noch
das hier ist jan bettink
zuwächse gemacht 30 millionen likes wird
sie 30 millionen likes gibt dann mache
ich nie wieder mein bett leute dann ist
das eure schuld spaß beiseite das ist
mein bett das ist mein lippi hat eine
beleuchtete tastatur normalerweise habe
ich hier in regenbogenfarben von links
nach rechts die beleuchtung
ausgeschaltet weil ich immer gemacht uns
geschaut und genervte tastatur
beleuchten kissen ihr mit treuen meter
komplett ladekabel in den wald rein und
hier also ein bisschen remscheider
fenster backbücher stärker fotos von der
paris reise mega lights übrigens falsch
von mir mit johanna super lady bei dir
meinen ausweis für die pariser metro da
habe ich im video glaub ich ganz viel
zeigt sie auf wie ein schwerverbrecher
war ich dennoch davon zwei schon
geschlafen habe dieser artikel ist der
zahn ich meinen drei kurven gewichts
gehört für styling sind nicht tastatur
portman über sein buchhaltungs belegen
so einen scheiß weil ich mich dafür
komischerweise interessiert also steuern
buchhaltung ich studiere auf was recht
und finanzen todesstern des schenkers
bitte fresse halten
das ist mein sound system einfach random
pc boxen whatever hat glaub ich jeder
oder planen hier hinten eine menge menge
kabel salaten jetzt gebt euch dass das
wurde mir mal geschenkt ich weiß nicht
warum das immer noch mein zimmer ist
darf man sowas eigentlich besitzen
endlich kann ich dafür ärger bekommen
nicht so ein ding habe da fand ich an
leute so universal
letztes mal arbeitsplatz hier zwei
bildschirme größer kleiner diesen
mikrofon ist eine rolle in teams absolut
basic phocuswright 24 scarlett ganztägig
die webcam obwohl standard dann ihre
absolute bildung tastatur 15 euro
gekauft oder so hier haben wir die
menschen dort wo ich selbst kaufen
musste sachs dann hier kopfhörer reform
macht es und hier auf meinem monitor
action hier in diesem regal ist einfach
mega viel scheiße generell einfach
scheiße da ist jeder mensch hat sie die
scheiß jeder mensch kennt die scheiße
und die meisten leute werfen die scheiße
nicht weg da haben wir hier natürlich
ganz oben den silbernen play button war
ganz ganz nah ist immer sommer darauf zu
schauen da kann man sich schon einen
drauf haben
hier werde ich auch noch ganz wichtig
mein pc für allerdings interessiert noch
mal kurz die specs ist eine gtx 67
trennen 16 quadraten intel i7 4097
prozessor kein k um das normale modell
und ich brauch mal neue grafikkarte
glaube ich läute eine sache ganz
vergessen es ist doch es 2016
wie kann man unter video machen ohne
seine sneaker vorzustellen schlimm
schlimm schlimm schlimm schlimm ein
großer großer fehler wäre jetzt mal zu
meinem knie gegangen
so wesentlich aber schuf man dabei
deswegen habe ich von mir sind die idole
von mir diesen mehr als diese von mir
und dieses turnier diesen familie diesen
verlieren diesen von mir
die sind von mir die sind von mir die
sind von mir diese von mir diesen von
mir diesen von mir 2000 krisen von mir
diese informiert die sind von mir die
sind von mir die sind von mir das war es
doch im großen und ganzen schon von
meinem zimmer wir machen jetzt mal ein
spiel okay wer zuletzt als verliert
kann